[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm KB HD here and
this is the LG G flex quite possibly the
most interesting phone in the world
right now so a video of this phone kind
of went semi viral last week from one of
LG's official YouTube channels of this
phone about its self-healing and
durability and ever since then that's
what people seem to want to know about
when they hear the name LG G flex so
that's what this video is for testing
the self-healing of this crazy
ridiculous looking new device now there
are two aspects to the self-healing of
this phone one the backing and actual
fancy material choices and to the actual
curved design or flex we'll get to that
in a second but for the backing material
in their video they scratched the phone
up and down on the back next to a
regular backing then after two minutes
of sitting the G flex actually
completely heals almost while the
regular phone is of course still scratch
now the back of this phone is actually
really smooth to the touch a very
velocity like the Galaxy s4 so it's easy
to tell when you've scratched it because
you can run your finger over the scratch
and feel it they have a bronze brush
rubbing up and down the back of the
phone with super even strokes I'm not
convinced that that translates into a
real life scenario unless you walk
around with a brillo pad or steel wool
in your pockets so I decided to do a
full test of my own the way I see a
self-healing phone to be applicable
against your keys because that's all I
can think of they put in the same pocket
or bag as your phone so it started off
pretty smooth I give it a few Clank some
scratches with the key to get it
legitimately scuffed up and simulate
being in the same pocket but the way I I
see it I really don't like intentionally
scratching your devices so I did this
for you guys so thumbs up for that down
below but sure enough after a few
minutes the scratches were mostly
minimized I say minimize not completely
gone but definitely way less noticeable
than when they were fresh this would be
awesome if you like dropped your phone
on the concrete and picked it back up
put it in your pocket walked home and
then took it out your pocket a few
minutes later and you'd barely even be
able to tell you drop your phone sounds
great but take a look back at that
official video from LG and you don't
exactly have to have eagle eyes to see
that that is an ad and that they're
using optimal controlled conditions for
that experiment and part of those
optimal control conditions that they
chose
was an air temperature of 27.4 degrees
Celsius which is 81 degrees Fahrenheit
the equivalent of a very warm summer day
I don't have those conditions where I am
right now I'm by New York City it's cold
it's windy it's maybe 55 degrees
Fahrenheit or 13 degrees Celsius on a
nice day out here so I decided to try to
simulate some of the heat to heal it but
actually rubbing against the scratches
really fast for a bit now as crazy as
you may look trying to warm up your
phone by clutching it to your body or
rubbing it really fast or playing some
intensive games as long as you're not
microwaving it you can actually
accelerate the healing process a little
bit by warming up the device and you
know that's a pretty neat trick now
finally I took a knife and took a deep
scratch clean across the back of the
device right under the lte-a logo and
tried a few things to warm up the device
and heal it and it's been a few hours
since then but the knife scratch isn't
completely gone in fact it's still I
mean it's about halfway gone barely
noticeable now and that's still way
better than any other traditional phone
material but it does take a while to
heal that's still impressive though now
the last part of this phone's
self-healing has to do with the name G
flex ladies and gentlemen do not try
this at home with your smartphone unless
somehow you also have an LG G flex
so basically this phone can completely
go flat from its curve and it's not
damaged at all internally I have no idea
what's going on here I mean it has a
3500 milliamp hour battery that's huge
it has a six inch display that's also
huge and it has all the usual parts like
processor RAM and everything but it does
hold up to the flexing just like they
demonstrate in their ad which is very
impressive pretty much no other phone
especially the other curved ones we're
looking at you Samsung Galaxy round will
come near this sort of resiliency so in
the end these two curved devices out
right now that are the most popular are
named quite perfectly the Samsung Galaxy
round is just that it's rounded and the
LG G flex while it actually flexes and
that's pretty impressive anyway be sure
to subscribe to be first to catch the
full review of the G flex plus much more
tech on the way you probably saw the ps4
stuff that I'm going through right now
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in next video peace
[Music]